a backyard in Soweto South Africa's
largest township twin brothers Marvin
and Eagle come here every day to get me
out it's a form of low grade heroin cut
with other substances and it's far
cheaper than pure reforms of the drug it
sold widely across South Africa there's
little fear of prosecution the one man
is small so detect stop from police fish
or to other cheetahs bring it here
I killed a man when the stuff is right
so criminal
according to a recent study poor
policing is behind the growing heroin
crisis in South Africa of their 4 euros
daily income as car guards Marvin and
Eagles spent half on Yelp II the one who
takes the first hit draws blood into the
syringe
he then injects this into his brother's
vein this dangerous practice is called
blue - thing it saves money but
transmits deadly diseases
the twins hoped to be able to get clean
one day he'd MHS in outs the insight
our things I want to live in a
fermentation I'm tired of it because no
please dangerous north of Pretoria the
organization agus acaba encourages drug
users to never give up hope
founder Moses let slow slow was an
addict in dealer himself it all changed
when he was caught with 60 kilograms of
marijuana at a London Airport in 2006
after spending four years in jail he
returned to South Africa and decided to
help other addicts turn their lives
around
[Music]
let's so slow strategy for reaching out
to fellow addicts is simple listening to
them making them feel that someone wants
to listen to me you know because of
those young boys and girls they are
victims of circumstances back with the
two brothers Eagle takes the first hit
then he injects his intoxicated blood
into Marvin Marvin stayed clean for six
weeks at the beginning of the year but
after watching Eagle get high every day
he started taking drugs again
but soon the brothers want to stay off
drugs together before it's too late
my first guest today is Shaun chilly he
is the founder of the South Africa Drug
Policy week it's an awareness program
welcome to 2dw Africa Shaun
so how widespread is the problem of
heroin and now figures in South Africa
well we don't actually know but it's
certainly increasing we haven't got
accurate figures there's there's no
daughter that one can rely on but we
know that it is certainly increasing and
that if there's an abundance of supply
and we are picking up more and more
issues around the use of heroin in South
Africa right Shaun certainly as we've
seen it from the protagonists in our
report
law enforcement isn't helping absolutely
not
we've got a lot of problems with the the
whole way that drugs are managed and you
know we deal with the use of drugs
within communities and no enforcement of
inch
become part of the problem becoming just
another defector gang in the situation
who bribery and corruption is is the
sort of standard in fact in parts of
South African law enforcement called
called drug users ATMs or automatic
teller machines Wow
and what if it is this having on South
African communities the communities
affected by this heroin and Yelper use
well you know the the issue is that the
communities as such are disintegrating
you know we're finding more and more
problems in communities and that's
driving the heroin use often which makes
people more marginalized and feel more
excluded and that's creating even more
of a problem again the the real issue is
what is making heroin so attractive to
people and what is it what is it that
they're finding in it that they're not
getting in their community so I think
the case is that there were already
problems in the community and these are
just exacerbated by the by the
availability of a drug which makes
things seem right and intolerable
circumstances tolerable you sort of
alluded to it to it as Sean but my next
question to you was really going to be
why now why are we being told that right
now heroin use is shooting up in South
Africa why is it so rampant now you've
got a confluence of factors first of all
we've obviously got more porous borders
there's more trade taking place
we've got more illicit products coming
out of Africa in general all products
that kind of thing and often that is
paid for with with drugs because it's
easier to move them and cash often and
we've got these porous borders plus
we've got a community that are feeling
disenfranchised and involved and
unconnected and that together creates a
kind of perfect storm for the undue
importance of drugs in people's lives so
I think that that's really come together
and with increasing urbanization where
we're seeing the rise of drug use
because it provides meaning and purpose
in people's lives might not look like it
from the outside but when they're
lacking meaning and purpose in day to
day activities they're going to look for
it elsewhere
Sean quickly here what can the South
African government do well I think the
first thing they've got to do is look at
alternative approach to drugs
and we know that putting people in jail
for drug use is not helping it drives
the situation it becomes the perfect
recruiting ground for gangsters and
means economic exclusion going forward
in the formal economy so we've really
got to find a different way of
approaching it we've gotta have more
prevention programs which start at
school level and that does not mean say
no to drugs prevention programs don't
even involve talking about drugs they
involve building stronger and better
communities all right
Shaun Shelley thank you